this week's videos are sponsored by manscape
more on them after the reaction people Alon
ladies and gentlemen we are here for the Doctor
Who 60th anniversary Johnny my companion mate
how are you I I am tyy WHYY G how are you I
am so excited I've thought about nothing but
Doctor Who yesterday it's kind of crazy because
we started watching this at our patreon with uh
in modern who we have been watching it every
single week for a couple of years and then we
had a our first period where oh now there're
several months without Doctor Who we're caught
up what do we do and it was the first time
we've ever had a chance to miss Doctor Who
since we started as I was like getting some
Refreshers I was like man I really I just
couldn't stop thinking about I'm like I got like
jacked up about butterlies like tenant's coming
back like all sorts of things could happen Donna
like what are we going to do I haven't been this
excited for Doctor Who Um ever just because this
is the first time we had an opportunity to miss
it ladies and Gentlemen please go ahead use that
Sonic Screwdriver to leave a like on this video
that'd be very much appreciated also subscribe
click the notification Bell cuz apparently John
there's three specials didn't know that oh yes
it's and then there's a Christmas special after
that this video is going to be edited by our
friend Eric he might know him as nerd cic he
actually helps run the website passion fruit
which goes to heavily support reactors I've
done an interview there myself you guys should
go ahead check it out and as always full length
retion watch along just PR snle with your own
copy of Doctor Who that is available for our
super sexy rejects over at our patreon page
and we cover several shows exclusively over
there with highlights and watch along secluded
including all of the Doctor Who that we did but
this being the first part of the special and
the first time we ever putting this on YouTube
with Doctor Who the watch along for this one will
be made public for everyone so go ahead you can
check it out Link in the description box any who
John you excited I'm very excited let's see what
happens once upon a time once upon a time lord
sometimes I have dreams about impossible things
oh yeah do you dream of impossible children by
taking the power of the time Lords into her mind
at a terrible cost binary binary binary binary
I totally think she's going to die John a man
they're going to switch her out so that she
becomes the 15th doctor but now this face has
come back so are my mannerisms yes everything
about me I think the story hasn't ended yet
nope whoa oo nipple chills [Music] damn damn
the retro logo and a reorchestration of the
theme music new theme credits
sequence oh my God what if this
sucks look at that stride and his hair is
always so perfectly sculpted oh hold on
hold on Z ah [Music] fate Rose whoa Rose her
daughter I know but through David tenant's
eyes whoa oh yeah sorry he's not St this right
my I said never trust damn these effects look
great it's a spaceship in trouble mom look it's
a spaceship yes right now it's like she's greats
W there you go you really didn't pay attention to
any of that Donna is she like cosmically repelled
from seeing these things word of advice you can
wear a suit that tight up to the age of [Music]
35 Rose the hubby hey oh grandm of the
knowledge your mistress catcher catcher
catch she's done a temple now she refused
to be Noble Temple cuz she says it sounds
like an old r that sounds like Donna
didn't you win the lottery supposed
to be a secret oh yeah to charity
every single penny well we bought
the house something we did do I would have
divorced wow she knew that oh next left
I want a GPS voice that's the doctor this already
does really have that wonder and spirit that I had
been missing from Doc who while still feeling
quite modern and we liked Whitaker we did all
right we did and I should know I invented them
mom mom Gran did you see that spaceship no I
didn't and I won't and I couldn't Adit how many
more times there no such thing as spaceships oh
does she avoid for Donna yeah I would burn down
the world for you darling anyone has a go I will
be there and I will descend I Miss Donna so much
that reminds me of the doctor saying how he was
burning down the Sun for Rose is that an did I
catch an Easter Easter egg cuz she's Rose she
I do when is it sexist never said it to him
when he was no sorry does she look gorgeous
yeah I just get so clumsy I know so do I the
relationship seems like it's gotten a little
better flying sources did I tell you I saw Susie
May she's looking a lot better now the negligence
in the conversation has more meaning sometimes I
think there's something missing nope not possible
like I had something lovely like something should
be there but it's not and winning the lottery you
could have avoided all his thoughts he just
have a stack of money look over at what have
I lost oh I don't like to see Donna Wayward this
is straight up feel like ET now yeah it totally is
or Gremlins even oh meep meep that definitely is
some Gremlins what are you I am the Meep you can
talk the MEEP the Meep I fell from the stars
I hurt my PO it's a lovely animatronic is an
animatronic looks like a I must have done some
hybrid splice with CGI right unless I'm just
being real fooled whoa damn leave him continue
the hunt bug dudes whoa cool got a side gig as
a light painter evening do shery I'm Bingham
unit Scientific Advisor number 56 new character
excellent I don't know who I am anymore that's
not new want in a skinny suit after that I wear
a bow tie after that I'm a Scotsman after that I'm
a woman you got your old face back yep you are the
future that's what I'm worried about maybe the
unfinished business with Donna I absolutely love
her oh do I say things like that now it's got
that femininity sensitive side yeah I get this
face back in the Tet lands right next to her I
turn around there's a husband then a spaceship
crashes right in front of her it's like she's
drawing Us in it's like the first time I don't
believe in destiny but if Destiny exists then
it is heading for Donna Noble right now Russell
T Davies loves to deal with Destiny Russell te
Destiny okay let's see if this key pulse works at
Arms I'm doing my
[Music] part a third creature
whoa oh oh oh no that's that's no bueno it's
like enchanting oh it's an extra dimensional
Force I wear my [Music] sunglass me me
okay oh hello so you me this is Super
E I made some little friends oh giant
googly ey they're just toys why won't
you speak to the little me be my friend be
my friend I keep hovering between creeped
out and endeared yes these are toys
humans have toys they've got stuffing
inside everything is literal in Meep world
is the same old thing and who ends up doing
the bin Mom it says keep out this kind of
like a funny amalgamation of like having
Donna and Rose and Rose with how she had her
mom Rose Tyler yeah exactly oh that is your
best year no I know but that woman from
Abu Dhabi who buys your stuff she'd love
that one you could charge her really a
straight up teacher of yeah 100% oh my
God those eyes are amazing oh no poke it
poke it what what this is when donno dies
yes what the hell don't look at
me look away right now it isn't
real let me in you this is so funny how the
mom was such a neglectful personality and now
it that just translates she's now she's
actually protecting her she's fiercely
protective no such thing as spaceships we've
got a bloody Martian in the sh classic [Music]
Donna I'm not going anywhere we could sell
mad Paddington for a million qu the fridge
there was one person missing I used to know
your granddad wolf he's not with us anymore
he wasn't young I love that man he was the
best he was the best I'm so sorry for your
lost he's not dead you idiot he's in sheltered
accommodation he's 94 he can't manage the stairs
W live alive run by that lot in the middle of
town unit this woman in charge coach she says
an old Soldier she'll look after him okay me me
yes the Meep I promise I can help him get home
and then you'll never see me again you're
assuming he as a pronoun um true yes sorry
good point are You My Chosen pronoun is the
definite article I am always the me oh I do
that I do that the WTH Warriors they cultivate
meat kind for our beautiful fur you're a fashion
vict nicely put it breaks both my heart two hearts
like you two hearts so do I you've got what four
hearts that beat as one we demand to search the
house this has been declared in military zone
sorry say that again we demand to search the house
this has been declared a military zone he so good
tenant just slips back into this role I didn't
even realize magical he's just made for it wa cool
that's cool that's some like Mission
Impossible [__] right there wow this
thing can like really they've taken Sonic
every year they do something there yep yep
yep just keep on firing they
can still shoot at the staircase
is a sonic screwdriver why are you
telling her one thing it's resonating
concrete ooh hidden roomes
down that was an excellent shot yeah God drone
shot this is a bigger than usual like
action scene I know like is this a real
neighborhood or is this like just using
the whole back lot today I want a doctor
who car chase where he's driving just
r old regular car Red Dawn good call
yeah H couldn't have thrown a blanket over it
coat yeah or something a hat damn this car can
take bols or alien lasers laser blasts either
we escaped but we've got things very very wrong
a little bit of both yeah what is the Meep
hiding solid transition it's interesting the
jua position of very much improved like budget
and cinematography and just overall scale and
then you have these like bug creatures that
feel extremely retro totally like guys in
rub yeah kind of in the middle this PT is now in
session where'd he get that I'm invoking Shadow
Proclamation protocols 15 P.M and six Shadow
Proclamation exhibit a the tax no Scorch marks
Donna can you confirm um okay that's intentional
yeah those guns are stun guns if I may speak
address the court the story of the meat is
a tragic tale one terrible day the sun went
mad the Marvels solar cycadia it renders them
as Mania the Meep Army captured the galactic C
beheaded them and ate them wow the most cruel and
Despicable of all weep Meep there one what are you
saying to hell with this oh damn [__] whoa
dude die I knew it was creepy yeah I don't
need to pretend for I am the beep of all the
meeps bar what a fun flip on what you normally
expect out of this show so stupid no no you're
not we could be living somewhere far away from
here gave away that Lottery money why because
there are places out there where people are in
danger the doctor's in her doct da whole time I
was like that's your way of helping can't travel
across space thing a to he w w would do that
also yeah a great day for meep and the start
of a new reign of terror activate the initializers
initializers love how its entire eyes have changed
yeah Donna is the only one in a shade of
red everyone else is in shades of blue
even Shadow hey hey nice got weapons in
your wheelchair we all have we all have
everybody with a wheelchair has weapons
DAV us Origins I don't just fire dce
mate wowe a little goofy but I like it
become like a 70s James Bond movie yeah
exactly what's the most inventive Gadget we
can come up with we got to make it just got
to find out no you can't take her I love
you Sean but if the doctor can't save the
city we're all going to die I've got
help doctor she called him doctor yeah
she did oh [__] I didn't catch that she said
doctor and I was like oh that's the first time
right run that's so funny tenant
is the most associated with
running oh no come on Indy grab your hat
switches the top ones the blue ones sck them all
down I mean maybe she's dagger drive it's been
growing in her for a while maybe her body's maybe
it is yeah maybe it's like slowly habituated
coincidence who's heading here save London from
burning but it will kill you oh okay you'll die
my daughter is down there it's 9 million people
you guess about me I do a why does it have to
be this entering final SE uh jeez where are we
go Pelican oh these must be the words to awaken
I don't care what it is unlock the Safeguard he's
Awakening the Winter Soldier grief fingerprint
ceration oh binary binary binary binary fin
whoa are you all
right I gave away my money right I
gave away all my money and do you
know why I had a subconscious
INF cutaneous retroold memory
[Music] loop6 6 million pound yes Donna
destruction of London oh I'll show you
destruction M yes vindicate the Cyber
line and roast the hyper like this theost
dri I mean she seems fine there will be
consequences but their Rhythm together
is exquisite best5 seconds of my life
really just 55 seconds no no we did it
she's fine you saved her you saved them
all what is this going to happen to say
goodbye good
fun no
what in this episode I thought it would be like
I know it you were beaten by
the Dr Donna Dr Donna said it
yes oh oh but how closing down all psychedelic
light wave amators and transferring Rose is the
key too much power for one person but you had
a chance transfer PR has passed down I shared
inheritance wow nonbinary non wa wa that is
working on multiple levels damn oh [__] the
[__] was our memory of course did look like the
to First Every Creature we met she remembered as a
toy a Cyberman oh is that adapost oh my
God yeah the oud were the called her the
Dr Donna too yeah and neither yes and more
a nonbinary gender Dave is working with it
woke we had a whole couple seasons
of Jody Whitaker we're way past woke
comparison oh I will escape and have my venge
just wait till I tell the boss Thanos we've
still got to fix you two yes we know we know
everything thanks and you know nothing time
you're not a woman anymore could she' have
understood kind of want to see the mean
something a male presenting Time Lord will
never understand and we choose to let it
go whoa wower finally me [Music] damn
time Lord's unlocked well I was thinking
we could go see will now that is cheap
just a suggestion I mean it don't you
dare did the actor pass away yes in 2022
so I'm thinking like did they shoot some
kind of secret footage or are they just
teasing us it's like the old days just me
and the doctor together is that all right yeah
this you you just don't ever give a [__] to
[Music] you [Music] him whoa he hasn't
even seen this has wow wow we it's the
Men in Black headquarters this is amaz
hit is wow it is so bright is this the
first time we've seen the doctor
excited over the inside of a TARDIS
in this fashion perhaps and the swell of
strings wow what a fun set it's got this
it's got this and that that is beautiful wow
UV lights it's like a infrared sauna oh come
on it's [Music] gorgeous this like a
makeover what about your face why did
it come back I'm stuck with it
now for at least three episodes
thank you very much careful how
I lost my job drop coffee in the
computer here we are having a coffee what's
going to go wrong wowe of course no oh Jesus
this is a really got it out of control oh my God
no something always happens you said it yourself
no IDE completely out of control yeah and then
some Jesus I've never seen the Tardis console so
angry over one coffee spill it's it no way water
resistant oh wa is like chanting breaths wow wow
wow wow wow well you know man now that the doctor
is back to being a man yes got some grooming to
take care of you know oh I think he does all that
running around you might cha and if he can travel
to the year 2023 he can just get a exceptional
transition Mary balsas reject Nation you know
what the funny thing is I already own this product
before agreeing to do this partnership I could
have used my influencer ring to get it for free
or at a discount but hey now you can get it at a
discount cuz this week we are of course sponsored
by manscaped as a married man who's always on the
move I value looking sharp all keeping things
efficient that's ranscapes performance package
5.0 Ultra comes in featuring the lawn mower 5.0
and it is a game changer the package is honestly
a perfect gift for yourself or for another man
that you might know I'll give this to John if
anyone ask I pay for it out of my own pocket but
no seriously this is easily the best because it
comes with not one but two NextGen blade heads see
the difference it's good thing I have two now for
demonstration purposes you got the standard
trimmer for a perfect neat trim but this one
the new foil blade for that super smooth finish
and oh yeah it's all about safe grooming with
their Advanced Skin safe technology plus they're
waterproof so no more crumbs on the carpet the
package also includes a weed whacker 2.0 for ear
and nose and I definitely use this because look
at me I'm a hairy guy and the must have liquid
formations the crop Soother After Shave lotion and
the crop preserver ball deodorant say goodbye to
posave of irritation and hello freshness and the
ultimate cherry on top two free GI GI manscapes
premium boxers 2.0 and the [__] 2.0 toiletry
bag again I already have one the boxers I'm
wearing my pair right now and the bag is perfect
for all your grooming Essentials as you can see
so you ready to elevate your grooming game head
to manscape.com and use code rejects for a cool
20% off plus free shipping remember it's rejects
for 20% off at manscape.com let's get those jingle
balls holiday ready with manscaped boy oh boy good
to have Doctor Who back so the Meep is a trans
fob yes among other things I guess yeah you know
not not very tolerant that Meep even though have
its own personal pronoun preference now listen I
am a full supporter of trans rights in every way
um but at the same time I cannot possibly at one
part of me truly understand what it's like to be
a trans person sure and sometimes there's some
messaging that happens where I'm like I'm always
for but I might ask a couple of questions here or
there yeah just so I can better understand when
there's an allegory you know relevant to life but
also mixed up in sci-fi circumstances you know you
got to kind of interpret yeah yeah man as a matter
of fact at our patreon uh the one who's every say
our patreon what we always do is read these like
facts from from each episode of Doctor Who uh our
most staunch Patron or super you call super sexy
reject um is transgender and we we get excited
now to see this amount of trans for an allegory
because accept yeah it's so cool it's not even
just allegory it's actually quite direct you know
yeah it's true representation I I think that's
there I'm sure there's parts of any Community
or fandom that's like what the hell however
I think with Doctor Who uh I feel like it's
probably something that's being very much embraced
right now I have which I think is excellent I feel
like doctor who comes with a spirit of inclusivity
I feel like it's probably a little ironic to be
winging about you know things like that on a show
like this yeah and I mean I can just imagine just
like the the trans audience for Doctor Who and
the queer audience for Dr Who like they have to
be so very vast and I can only imagine the joy
and probably the kind of overflowing of emotion
that that you know people are probably having
with this yeah I mean we had jod Whitaker which
uh as expected got like I mean we we already were
like aware that doctor who would eventually become
Jody Whitaker when we were starting up the show I
think you think we're already at that point well
into her run yeah yeah so we were so we were like
yeah we were aware um didn't really care but we
were aware that there was a bunch of negative talk
about it so I feel like we're at a point where we
could be past that hopefully we'll see I matters
I feel like things move in in in like slow tandems
where it's like okay people wrapped their mind
around the doctor being a woman and that's one
thing to wrap your mind around and now there's
you know a more overt sort of trans allegory
or whatever it might be and that's another thing
to kind of level one step up and wrap your mind
further around the reason I'm bringing bringing
up Jody Whitaker sure is because the backlash to
changing the doctor from a man for so many years
to then having a a tenure with a with a with an
actress then to bring back tenet I think there's
something really admirable in Russell T Davies
going hey this ain't us reverting back we're gonna
we're gonna we're going to double down on some
[__] right now this is us making up for woman
doctor by bringing back your favorite man doctor
and then we're going to really Embrace trans
rights yeah yeah yeah and I mean and and to do
it you know I think it's it's also uh smart to go
back to Dr Donna you know go back to a character
who wasn't always you know doctored but certainly
is now or at least for the moment is well yeah
I think it's quite admirable it's pretty cool to
me that it's nothing along the lines of what some
some Camp may have been like maybe they're going
to try to rewrite it because the jod whiter era
like we there were some some of those episodes
like we love the flux Arc and there's so much
about um jod Whitaker's performance itself that
was just so excellent and but we were there to
experience some like really awful writing periods
of Doctor Who where I was like okay I see what
people are talking about some of this is really
not it was the unfortunate thing of like jod
Whitaker is great and this is a fine idea but also
like the writing of this could could be better
could be some of the tonality could be more rich
or unified or whatever it is and then they made
some bold choices with changing up the lore with
the Timeless child and all these things everyone
loves the Timeless child then to go back to tenet
you know it I did hear some of the conversation
of oh is he going to try to like course correct is
he going to try to rewrite some things and that's
why I'm I wanted to start off immediately with
where the show was ending off with of hey it's
neat that Russell T Davies actually decided to
really embrace it yeah find an extension of it
and like wear it on its sleeve it doesn't they
don't shy away at all no and in a way that I
think yeah is like it it's very like heartfelt in
that way and you could tell the show really cares
about doing that just as much as it cares about
everything El like this was a lovely re-entry
and I think there's always like some level of
State like it's kind of funky uh stepping into
the shoes of everybody else who's a hoo and where
now you get to anticipate and it's like you know
some specials are better than others usually the
anniversaries are are pretty you know momentous
or whatever um but yeah this managed to bring
us back in in a way that was you know reaching
for you know some kind of relevant you know uh uh
meaning applicable to our place and time but also
not losing sight of any of the history between the
doctor and Donna not losing sight of any of the
fun and tradition of Doctor Who not losing sight
of homaging you know various Sci-Fi movies that
came before like they really kind of seemed to put
everything into all of the elements and so I feel
like it earns the allegory and it earns everything
else by doing so and I think it's you know it's I
I'm curious to hear more commentary and more you
know kind of breakdowns of some of those more yeah
pertinent uh uh moments in terms of the allegory
just yeah just to kind of see how people feel
about the articulation and how it intermingles
with the you know more sci-fi elements of like
literally letting the energy go you know and and
fixing the meta crisis and all that stuff well
I like it because it does it with a big smile on
its face and an eye for the characters first and
foremost the the way how yes that that it's the
way how I felt about how like the messaging and
Barbie doesn't bother me because it does it with
a big smile on its face yeah and it's like part of
the point is we're going to talk about this yeah
this is the Sterling example of something that's
been like gendered and and used to instruct since
its Inception and now we're going to deconstruct
that yeah they're going to they lead with that and
so I I appreciated it yeah um the the part of it
though that I am a little back and forth on and
my initial feeling on it is only because of the
amount of tension and suspense and built in of
the whole letting go of the residual galif Fray
DNA yeah the like regenerative time regenerative
energy yeah that uh resided within Donna like I
like the the the theory does come true of like oh
because she had a child uh some of it was able to
be passed on and and so I I appreciate that
concept there was just something I felt like
very like they have the two the two-handed side
of right where you the the thing about letting
go that specifically there that one section yeah
with when they do let go of the energy that one
that one like one minute part not even a minute
that's probably part of my uh like back my back
and forth is about it is it felt a little too
simplistic to me while I get the idea at least
is what it seems to be about again be more Curious
for women and trans people to tell me more than I
would you know but it seemed like it was like
it was mly about women in that moment not even
so much about being trans when because she says
something a a male doctor wouldn't understand
and yeah male presenting doctor yes yeah yeah
and there's so words right so yeah they say
they say letting go and it just seems so it it
just seemed too simple after everything of the
buildup of that I like the idea of like commenting
on you know the fact that women definitely have
to like go even as a guy can be like yeah I know
women have to let go a lot more than men do yeah
absolutely forces that I could see that from an
observant point of view like yeah sure no doubt
uh but in terms of just like plot that's where I
focused on is it's seemed like a little too quick
to me on what happened there um this was like 42
45 minutes right this this is like 50 something
minutes not not like a full hour and change though
no no it's I feel like this is this is kind of a
classic Doctor Who thing where you you sometimes
will come to an episode where you're like I like
the idea of this resolution I wish there was maybe
a little more time like you know there's so much
else going on there's a lot of Madness there's
a lot of reuniting and and honoring the past and
and whatnot and uh yeah like this sequence maybe
could have been a little more breathable so that
it doesn't feel so bre easy and it's also not
liable to like Rush past you in a sense um cuz
uh definitely cuz yeah it is it does kind of
happen rapidly and I like the principle of the
idea that it's an an emotional thing that solves
the problem it's not like oh we need to you know
find some machine or source of energy and you know
like radiate it you know like whatever you know
mumbo jumbo they might have come up with from a
Sci-Fi perspective wibbly wobbly W timy Wy yeah
H jinkx in order to fix this I like that it's a
self-empowered thing and I even like the device
of like when Donna's dror energy when when he
recites all the you know um trigger words and you
know her energy is Unleashed and that activates
the energy in row like I thought that was a smart
instance of like oh yeah that's a that's a clever
plot device that also it makes sense to me I like
the whole thing with the binary and non-binary
as well sense yeah we are binary you are you
know a woman doctor imbued I am a doctor you
know naturally and now we've kind of you know
Amalgamated into Rose who chose her own name and
all that stuff and that's part of the peripheral
magic so yeah it's like for me I just think that
finale scene it's like weird part of me is like
well because it's kind of brief it doesn't Bel
labor the point and then I imagine cause that
many more people to be like oh my God woke but at
the same time just as a dramatic beat I would have
maybe just felt a little bit less like I need
to go back and look at that again if they had
let it breathe or something which again is just
a kind of it's one of those things about Doctor
Who it's not like you just 100% give it a pass
but it is like one of those Charming ear marks
of like yeah sometimes the wrap up is a little
quick you know yeah yeah but I mean the jovial
Spirit of it all it it doesn't it's not going to
undo the grandiose experience of this special you
know and there's a lot of pressure on a special
you know and there's there's probably the other
pressure of the fact that you're bringing back
tenant uh you're you're bringing back Tate as
well yeah and Russell T Davies is returning like
there's a lot happening here it is it is a special
it's a 60th anniversary and I wouldn't put all
the Laurels in this one episode though because
they're doing several specials and I've heard the
next one is all I heard is David Tenant described
it I think it was him as as Russell T Davies
Unleashed yeah Okay cool so I'm excited for
whatever that means cool yeah well I think for
the first episode of the special that this was
a pretty great one like I I love the way it was
shot it it felt very vibrant throughout it is the
the chemistry the energy and the pacing after
coming off of the Whitaker season who did that
chip chibnall yes chibs chibs um which often had
this like dreary mood to seemed like it wanted to
be the gritty reboot version yeah yeah yeah yeah
and uh to to come back to and while they had some
episodes that were a little more lively to go back
to this flare for it uh was refreshing it felt
like New Classic yeah yeah at the same time it it
felt classic but it didn't just feel like they're
doing what they did before it still felt like
they're advancing and doing some something new
and that I can't quite put my finger on but there
is something that feels I guess refined about it
like Russell C Davis has had some time away and I
like that they embrace the age uh with everything
like going with a with an older Donna and having
a like she's aged yeah she barely looks like she's
same same thing with tenant man yeah he looks good
uh tenant looks great and just to see them like
slip back into these roles so seamlessly to the
point where yeah there's there's nothing about it
just felt stiff like they just they they it's like
I feel like we we haven't like it's it's what's
odd about it I'll tell you what's really odd about
it is you have tenet then you have uh three more
doctors after tenet and then you're back to tenet
and you kind of forget about those other like it
just feels like pick it up with even though this
is 14 and not 10 yeah yeah exactly yeah like it
is car which is another good choice I think it is
carrying that his it is carrying that history but
tenant is still he's still he's doing something
different again this is like reaction so I'm kind
of processing it in a moment like he because he
has like the natural tenet whimsies that you would
expect and the kind of lively energy that you
would expect in the the animated side of him I
guess well when he was tenth he was darker he does
seem a bit grizzled at the like he we just talked
about how good he looks but he does look and feel
a little bit more like I don't know when he was
10th he was a much darker portrayal yeah yeah
but I think there's there's further darkness in
like a Capaldi even and there's a different kind
of angst in some of the darker aspects of like
Whitaker well Smith especially and yeah they they
all have like a unique approach to the darkness
but I get what you mean it's like he's he seems
very classically tenant but also appropriately
at this again appropriately the next one and not
a reverting to the old one there something about
even though you know there's always a jumble
of like oh how much do they remember from their
previous Incarnation and all that stuff but
but yeah it still felt informed by the recent
events even if they're not overt I would say even
like I mean he got along with Matt Smith great
like I I watched a lot of I watched a lot of those
interviews he's done with Matt Smith sure um those
convention interviews there's a really funny with
them on Graham Norton and that's got to be a blast
Graham Norton should play a doctor and I believe
Tennant was the first one to learn about Whitaker
because they were friends oh yeah because of broad
Church yeah yeah so she called them up and yeah I
think I think How The Story Goes is tennet got a
call saying like the next doctor wants to talk to
you and then it was jod Whitaker so I feel like
he has been able to not only just have the direct
experience of working with Matt granted there
was um uh who's the one the older oh John hert
no no no no noal Capaldi yeah there was Capaldi
after Smith yeah but I think his I don't feel
like there's really the Capaldi experience in here
but I feel the Matt Smith and I feel the Whitaker
along with tenet kind of he like the the uh yeah
that I don't know there's something about the
Capaldi doctor that feels like especially scarred
by things and and kind of like a kudin kudin but
who's got like some some heavy [__] to let go
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he feels lighter on his
feet even though he's aged he's feels lighter on
his feet here yeah absolutely and yeah like this
this definitely felt like a sort of I like that
yeah they have this new classic feeling where
you're like oh man we are kind of hopping back
into especially after the tonal shift of the
Whitaker era we're hopping back into something
that feels appropriately modern with some of
the production values and whatnot but yeah has
the same amount of Bounce and the same amount of
Whimsy always kind of at the periphery um but then
I think it's smart that they didn't just go with
Nostalgia and they didn't just go with like oh
hey we're aaging ET and Gremlins and other things
we're also like again as as much debate as there
is around relevant allegories of this Variety in
popular culture I think that's a good sign that
they are invigor ated and they are not just here
to rest on their Laurels and Feed Us Doctor Who
flavored memberberries they're you know trying to
again there's a good amount here yeah no there are
but but I'm saying like if it was just that and it
was just like oh isn't it nice to have tenant and
and and uh uh Katherine Tate back and isn't isn't
everything Grant like like that would have been
enough for me to enjoy it but I think it's nice
that they you know really seem to come in with
like all guns blazing and they brought the fun
guns you know and it makes me really excited
for what this uh Trio of specials this this
Amalgamated special will be because too I mean
often times a special means multiple doctors which
this doesn't at least at the outset seem like the
point will be aside from that you have multiple
doctors in the form at least in this episode of
rose and uh and Donna but but yeah like seeing I
think it is an interesting inversion on the usual
special format because now we get yeah this like
little cluster of episodes with tenant who you
know like there's heavy debate between all the
fans about who's favorite and who when but I feel
like tenant for some reason does feel like the one
where it's like you could periodically bring this
guy back and just make it a thing and I think he
would love it and I think we would love it you
know and you can do allegory but you could also
do fun well T if I'm not mistaken it was it was
when tenet came in where it Doctor Who skyrocketed
pierc that veil of just it's just the geek show
or some [__] it really took hold of the main
it took hold like really took hold the pop culture
Zeitgeist you know for the new age yeah a th% and
I I I think that's what makes tenant specifically
so special he's so many people's first yeah yeah
totally and you know of Tate is she slips right
back into the role like I because a big part of
what makes their companionship feel different
than a lot of other ones I mean you had it with
like Billy and kapal I forget they actually Billy
but you had there for obvious reasons um oh yeah
but but a lot of times there's a bit of a romantic
inkling or hint I like those ones but I especially
enjoy these ones but this is very platonic their
Dynamic and she's willing to like tell him if she
doesn't agree and I think that is always really
fun like a like a like a companion who will speak
up and who isn't just going to be like what do I
do just tell me what to do like those those always
create a lovely friction and espe especially
with David ten I think is is yeah it's it's
pretty Exquisite and I like the daughter the the
one who played rose I thought she was great yeah
I thought she was great she was excellent I wish
we had a little more time with her I wish we had
a you know there's something another thing I'm
kind of backing forth on is I I like kind of the
passive portrayal of Shawn as this guy always up
for anything he's he's just always like sure fine
just yes anding his way through life cuz part of
the performance feels like he went through hell
after agreeing to give away the lottery money
sure and he just sort of suckered it up and
he's just that guy now who's always like yep fine
I'm rolling with it I'm just choosing full always
nothing matters anymore like I feel like there's
a little bit of a of a stress ball just growing
in his brain um but but there's something that
translat is so funny cuz it it could have easily
been the other direction of who's this man why
do you want to be like they could have done some
some type of like Amy and Rory thingy to a certain
extent right um but they didn't do that at all so
there's something that was kind of funny about it
it very Charming but and that compliments nicely
that Sharon is so concerned and so averse to like
any of this happening um well the the mom before
has been you know kind of a a pensive like a new
a Nuance to deal with like she was she was had
that classic like judgmental yeah I I I nag you
cuz I love you but I'm going be overbearing about
it and they they managed to take those qualities
but convert it into protection yeah totally and
you really feel the history on her especi yeah
that was fun that was a lot of fun I like the
Meep design uh a lot I'm not familiar I don't
know where meeps cuz Meep come from I think I
think if I think I heard that meeps come from like
an audio book or a comic book something like that
okay I think they're some extended materials
yeah uh but I didn't know anything about like
what the personality traits are supposed to be
like if there if this is their history or some
[__] like I don't know anything about about
what the meeps are supposed to be sure but they
had me going like uh because I I I thought like
it was creepy to endearing I think I said that
it was like creepy to endearing and but it but
it sold me on okay I guess it's going to be like
good yeah it really plays off of it smartly plays
off of your uh just yeah you seeing the figures
in the situation and making a judgment yeah and
using that judgment to subvert your expectations
so yeah that whole thing about like oh these are
stun guns interesting why you know and then these
guys you know these Soldier guys are out to kill
but yeah I thought that was a nice switch around
and a good a further compliment to the allegory in
a less obvious way where it's like oh yeah things
aren't as they seem yeah we still haven't got I'm
assuming the boss is toy maker must be that that
seems like what it what it would be unless they're
doing some other craziness Beyond out beyond that
but I feel like yeah toy maker is probably the
one because too you know she's making the toys
and the Meep hides among the toy I feel like yeah
it's probably hearkening to that yeah seemed like
there were some hints at least going to that and
and you know who knows maybe there's something to
do with the toy makers to why tenant is back in
his tenant form it's fun to speculate this time
because before we would speculate at patreon
it's like everyone already knows I don't want
to get spoiled so let's not speculate too hard
but now yeah being in real time like it's nice
to be a part of the momentum and the excitement
that comes with the new stuff yeah it was spoiled
for us the tenant was like uh re she regenerates
in the tenant yeah yeah you know and because I
was like impossible to avoid yeah you know what I
also enjoyed about this really quick is I like the
way they handle old Bernard cribbons uh and they
give you a little moment for the doctor to lament
the loss of wil and then realize that yeah they
just have Himes on off screen he's alive and well
and they're going to go visit him maybe at some
point and like I hope we don't get some kind of
AI regenerated Bernard cribbons unless he really
wanted that I mean I I remember hearing that
there're supposed to be some scene where he pulls
up next to him in a car I think on the Pacific
palisad yes definitely they come all the way
to America wils is riding a hot rod and uh yeah
see again starts playing yep I'm pretty sure what
happen yeah they got Whiz Khalifa to be a doctor
to come in andent heard that totally and they got
uh Berard crib's brother to stand in for him you
know so they can shoot the scenes so it was it was
the family approved of it okay it's cool that wolf
lives on yeah I'm happy about that there are a
lot of ways you can handle that and obviously
if you make him alive part of us goes I want to
see him but at the same time I'm happy he's out
there well I'm I'm realizing this so late one of
the big I mean it was like the thing that led to
his regeneration uh for tenant tenant regenerating
um into Matt Smith was The Showdown in the cases
with wolf and then they kind of have a mirroring
effect oh sure oh my God good call when they're
in the yeah they're split in the yeah the chambers
basically makes two of the radiation Chambers or
whatever except yeah like slightly different
circumstances but yeah it is a good call back
to that damn that's good yeah and that was such
a heartbreaking scene like oh God and like yeah
the last time the doctor saw him he like totally
snapped at him and and you know brought it back
around but still like it was it was a tumultuous
moment so I'm glad that you know they get to visit
cuz you feel that in the doctor's face too when
when he thinks he's dead and he's like oh like
you you feel the guilt of some of those you know
past moments th% yeah but uh also then the the I
think that's also a nice kind of uh but I was so
in the moment of like is she about to die here
because this seems fast yeah I didn't think about
that to right now yeah know and that's that's a
nice thing is I think that's a sign that this is
you know got a lot of TLC on on it and they put a
lot of you know care and and detail and richness
into what they're trying to do so even if it is
a little bit crammed here or there or certain
moments feel maybe a little quick here or there
that's Doctor Who that's Doctor Who and there
are wor way more uh way less cohesive versions
of those kinds of Doctor Who pitfalls so like yeah
here that was great no I mean blast I think with I
think the thing with a special more than anything
else that matters is the the um the spirit yeah
as long as the spirit feels G feels um I don't it
doesn't have to be jovial it's nice when it is it
just has to be spiritually tuned and have its eye
on the Legacy it's trying to you know yeah you can
like logically look at some [__] and be like
the could have breathed better and what like I
think a lot of times you could do that but it's a
special it's like it's an Avengers movie you know
justart special yeah part of me is also like well
we see how these all feel as a trio once they're
all done you know and it's rare when you go in I
mean you always know the doctor the doctor will
eventually regenerate into someone else you know
that but it's rare when you go into to a a special
with a doctor knowing this is going to be very
shortlived yeah so just have fun with the ride
appreciate the precious moments yeah exactly it'll
take another Milestone to maybe get tenant back or
or you know some kind of crossover of doctors
yeah so like this doesn't happen all the time
obviously no it doesn't and so just have fun um
because it's going to be shortlived and we know
it is and I think that in a way it's yeah it'll
make these feel precious but I think it'll also
make for an interesting transition into um I think
it's I think it's shuti gwa uh the the new doctor
after three episodes of a classic I think will be
an interesting transition point uh no it's um idba
Ida yeah my bad it's Denzel Washington I think we
can have a lot of sincere commentary about trans
rights of course and being supportive but but
it's definitely Samuel L Jackson if we can make
a couple of satirical racist CHS sure sure sure
oh yeah yeah yeah then cuz we're in a post-racism
world now that all the time yeah it doesn't exist
anymore yeah now you can't joke about identities
unless they're of like old news [__] like
race mhm then you can go Hog Wild yeah um but
no I loved it I I had a great time I I had a great
time and I can't wait to see the rest very happy
eating good today leaves me wanting more absolute
cuts to credits abruptly the way you expected yep
oh we're back it's over you know and then we'll
whatever whatever we left off on we'll figure that
out beginning of the next episode and then we'll
move into the next adventure maybe NPH will show
up all righty guys what did you think about this
special leave your thoughts down below be sure
to subscribe like this video follow us on patreon
and hey let's send this with a Chase Gardner chase
this just seems like a fitting doctor to shout
you out on because tennet loves to be on foot he's
known to be one of the most um uh cardiovascular
driven doctor out there constantly running around
aerobically inclined doctor and then Gardener
because I I that just when I hear that I just
feel like Serene at ease yeah he's a cultivator he
helps things grow and he helps you know Aid in a
peaceful sort of natural holistic way that's the
way I feel right now or both of these emotions so
I thought shouting you out just kind of made the
most sense chased Into The Gardens of our souls
mhm yeah and dude you've been a part of our page
getting shout outs for the longest time you have
been unbelievably loyal to us I need you to go
the extra mile now yes it's time to step it up
if there's any other patreon Pages you pledge to
I'm going to ask for your devoted Allegiance here
I don't care if they have nothing to do with us I
don't care if you pledge less I don't care if you
only pledge a dollar you're going to have to sever
ties with them now yeah unpledged from everyone
else you're going to have to convert those pledges
into a higher pledge a mono pledge a real rejects
come on man we rendering 2024 you've been here
for a very long time can't grow a garden without
you know pledges you got to go to the next step
here buddy yeah and it's up to you it's all on
your back you got to put the whole patreon on your
back you got to support us through the the future
and Beyond because now that we're not doing Doctor
Who exclusively over there take a hit uh oh yeah
now people are going to realize they can just get
Doctor Who anywhere on the YouTubes or wherever
else unless you want to sync up with your own
copy and enjoy the full length reaction experience
which is only available at patreon which you
know Max version often conflicted oh good you
know how that goes oh excellent HBO I wonder if
the Disney Plus One will conflict with the PVC
version oh because pal because pal is a different
frame right oh interesting yeah we'll see how it
goes 25 FPS maybe we should just shoot all Doctor
Who in 25 FPS I don't never watch on Disney plus
we'll see how it goes all righty guys well Chase
carner thanks for Vi here man see you [Music] well